اتخذ المجلس الاسرائيلي المصغر للامن
برئاسه بنبينه ياهو اجراءات عقابيه ضد
الفلسطينيين تضمنت تسهيلات لمنح
الاسرائيليين تراخيص اسلحه اضافه الى
تعزيز اجراءات الامن في المستوطنات وقال
نتنياهو في تصريح استبق به زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطون بريكن المرتقبه
ان حكومته لا تبحث عن التصعيد ملوحا برد
سريع وحازم على العمليات الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات في اي اتجاه يذهبون
نتنياهو في سياسه حكومه وقراراتها بعد ما
اثبته الوقائع عن السياسه العنف والتنكيد
بالفلسطينيين تواجهوا برد ميدانيا فلسطيني
المقابل ما هي العوامل والحسابات الداخليه
لنتنه المؤثره في نهج حكومه وتعاملها مع
الفلسطينيين في المرحله المقبله في ظل
سعيه لارضاء اليمين المتطرف في حكومته
واستمرار احتجاجات المعارضه الاسرائيليه
ضد في الشارع وما هي حساباته الخارجيه
لاسيما في ضوء زياره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه المرتقبه التي سيبحث فيها غدا
وقفه تصاعدي حده التوتر في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وهل تنجح المسائل الامريكيه في
كبح جماح العنف والحيله التي دون تفجر
الاوضاع في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
يجني نتنياهو ما زرعته الشعرات والبرامج
التي رفعها في حملته الانتخابيه وهو يجني
كذلك مستثمره في تشكيله حكوميه توصف
بالاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ اسرائيل هكذا يقرا
منتقده سياسات رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
والفريق الحكومي على وقع التصعيد الجاري
في القدس والضفه وقطاع غزه بما يشمله من
عمليات العسكريه اسرائيليه واخرى فلسطينيه
ردا على ما تخلفه من شهداء وجرحى
فلسطينيين نتنياهو الواقف هذه الايام في
المربع العاصف الذي تلتقي فيه حسابات
المعادلات الداخليه سياسيا وامنيا بزيارت
امريكيه متتاليه ستبلغ ذروتها بمجيء وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الى المنطقه قال بعيده
لاعلاني عن الاجراءات الانتقاميه بحق
الفلسطينيين ان حكومته لا تبحث عن التصعيد
لكنها متاهبه للتعامل مع كل احتمال رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اضاف نحن جاهزون لاي
طارئ وردنا على العمليات الاخيره سيكون
قويا وسريعا في الاثناء وصل بلانكن الى
القاهره محطته الاولى في جوله تقوده الى
تل ابيب ورم الله لملاقاه القاده فيها في
ابرز الملفات التصعيد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه والتخفيف من حده التوترات
والوضع التاريخي في القدس وملف حل
للدولتين
[موسيقى]
النقاش في هذا الموضوع الينا في بدايه هذه
الحلقه من تل ابيب السيد امير اورين
المحلل السياسي والعسكري لشؤون الامن
القومي والسياسه الخارجيه الاسرائيليه سيد
امير هل الحكومه نتنياهو موحده وقويه في
مواجهه الوضع المتفجر على الارض
ناوي دفنت لينو
هي غير موحده هناك القسمات في داخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومن الواضح انها لا
تحظى بدعم مصر الناخبين الاسرائيليين ولكن
كما ذكرتم في مقدمتكم من ضمن الحكومه هناك
اشخاص من الجناح المتطرف وبالنسبه الى
نتنياهو ليس في مصلحته ان يشهدت الصعيدا
على الجبهه الفلسطينيه لان لديه مسالتان
لتعيين عليه ان يتعامل معهما المتاعب
القانونيه اولا والمساله الايرانيه ثانيا
اذا ما اراد ان يغضب الدعم الامريكي على
المستوى الايراني لا يمكنه ان يتطرف على
المستوى الفلسطيني ولكنه لا يمكن ان يقرر
ما المصير بالنسبه اليه لان الوزراء من
اليمين المتطرف يودون ان يروا اج اكثر
تطرفا ويحاولون ان يؤثر على نتنهو في هذا
الاتجاهات التي اعلن عنها نتنياهو ردا على
عمليتي القدس
لحسب ما يقول وقف اي عمليات في المستقبل
الحديث عن مصادره منازل هدم هذه المنازل
زياده الاستيطان والحديث ايضا عن تسريع
منح تصاريح حامل سلاح للمستوطنين
الاسرائيليين الا يزيدها من احتقان الشارع
وبالتالي مزيد من التوتر على عكس ما يريد
نتنياهو كما يقول
يا سكر
هذا صحيح ولكننا نتحدث عن مبادرات فارغه
لا هدف منها ولا نتيجه لها فقط يود ان
يهدي من روعي الناس ولكن لن تؤثر بنسبه
الى ردع الهجمات في المستقبل عندما نتحدث
عن مصادره المنازل وخصوصا مصادره منزل
عائله الطفل في الثالثه عشر من عمره هذا
لا يؤدي الى تغيير
المعادله وهذا لن يمنع الفلسطينيين من
تنفيذ العمليات وبعد اياما قليله سوف
تتبخر هذه الاجراءات ولكن يجب ان نتذكر ان
نتنياه لديه همم
يعاني من ضغط بنسبه الى الوقت ولكن لا
اعتقد ان هذه الاجراءات ناجحه ذكرت سيد
امير بان نتنياهو يحتاج الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا سيما في مواجهه
ايران وحزب الله كما تفضلت بالمناسبه قبل
ساعات فقط اعلن عن استهداف مسيرات
اسرائيليه لمنشئه عسكريه في اصفهان في
الداخل الايراني بالتالي ااا على جدول
اعمال بل في مقدمه جدول اعمال زياره بلنكن
هو التخفيف التصعيد في اسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه ما الذي يمكن ان يقدمه نتانيا
للحليف الامريكي
سوق بيكاسو منشن ده
كرتون توم ايران والهجوم الذي استهدف
اصفهان هذا الامر يرتبط بالحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه اذا ما كانت روسيا تستورد
الاسلحه وخصوصا المسيارات من ايران
واذا ما كانت اسرائيل باستطاعتها ان تقصف
المصانع هذه النقطه ايجابيه بنسبه الى
علاقه بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده بغض
النظر عن الامور الاخرى اما بالنسبه الى
ما يمكن ان يقدمه نتنياهو هو تجديد
المباحثات والمحادثات مع الرئيس محمود
عباس للسنوات 14 المنصرم بما في ذلك في
حكومات بنت لم يكن هناك من اتصال رسمي بين
رئيس مجلس الوزراء والرئيس واذا ما عاد
عاد الوزير من هذه الزياره واعلن ان هناك
عدد من الاجتماعات سوف تعقد سواء كانت على
مستوى الثنائي او الثلاثي في واشنطن او في
المنطقه هذا يساعد الرئيس بايدا في جهوده
اعاده انتخابه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وربما ايضا يساعد بشان ما يحصل
في المنطقه شكرا لك يا سيد امير اورين في
تل ابيب
لتعميق النقاش ينضب الينا من واشنطن
السفير بيجي كراولي المتحدث السابق باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه ومن الخليل السيد عادل
شديد الباحث المختص بشان الاسرائيلي مرحبا
بكما سيد عادل كيف يبدو لك تعامل نتنياهو
مع التطورات ومنتج عنها من تصعيد للعنف في
اسرائيل والاراضي الفلسطينيه
تحياتي لك يا استاذ جلال
وضيفك ولا للمشاهدين
ما حدث بالامس تحديدا عمليه سلوان واول
امس عمليه النبي يعقوب القدس
الجديده
بالشارع الاسرائيلي ضد سياسات حكومه
نتنياهو اتجاه داخل اسرائيل ولكن يبدو ان
وقوع العمليتين النوعيتين بالقدس جعل
نتنياهو يشعر ان الامور في لحظه ما قد
تخرج عن السيطره بالتالي كان واضح تماما
بالقرارات التي اتخذت اليوم وبالامس من
اجتماع الكبينيت المجلس الوزاري المصغر
الامني ثم اجتماع الحكومه انه انه بصمات
في الحكومه العميقه شركاء نتنياهو جماعه
بن كزير واسموتريج واللي هو بيحتاجهم
باتجاهين الاتجاه الشخص الاول ان هم
الوحيدين القادرين على انقاذ واخراج
نتنياهو من ازمه القانونيه وملاحقه
القضائيين ثم هو ينسجم الى حد ما معه
اكثريه مواقفهم السياسيه تجاه الفلسطينيين
والقضيه الفلسطينيه باستثناء اختلافهم حول
علاقه الدين بالدولي وحول رؤيتهم اتجاه
الحقوق الفرديه
الابراهيميه لشرائح واسعه من المجتمع
اليهودي وبالتالي نتانيا اهو يحاول همم
الامتحان باقل الخسائر بحيث ان يحافظ على
ايه الحكومه على ثبات الحكومه وعدم تصدعها
من الداخل ثم يوظف ما يحدث لمواجهه خصومه
بالداخل تحديدا همم الجهاز القضاء
والمستشاره القانوني وهمم
الخصوم اللي بينزلوا للشارع وكان اخرها
بالامس ولكن باعداد اقل نتيجه التطورات
الامنيه وعمليتها القدس ثم الحفاظ على
العلاقات العامه سواء مع الاداره
الامريكيه اللي لها مجموعه من
المبعوثين واخرهم غدا وزير الخارجيه واللي
واضح انه الامريكان الاسرائيليين اليوم
نتنياهو تحديدا معني جدا بالحفاظ وتطوير
العلاقه ليس فقط
للحاله التقليديه ال- التحالف القائم ما
بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل وانما
لمختلف القضايا سواء الموضوع الايراني
سواء الحفاظ على السياق
طبيعيه
هل توضح لك باي اتجاه
سياسير بنيامين الثانيه الذي يقول بانه لا
يريد التصعيد ولكنه جاهز لكل الخيارات
ابي شريده
اعمال العنف الاخيره قد اضافه نوعا من
الضروره القصوى لهذه الزياره لوزير
الوزير يزير يزور المنطقه لمحاوله معرفه
كيف ما هي خطوات
الحكم وكيف سيتعامل مع التناقضات ضمن
التحالف الحكومي
الوضع الحالي وما الذي ينوي القيام به وهو
سيشركه الرئيس عباس ايضا الذي له تاريخ
طويل وتاريخ صحفي نفس الوقت
العظمى من القرارات التي اتخذتها الحكومه
المصغره اعود واذكر بها بطبيعه الحال همم
اهمها على ما يبدو هو زياده وتسريع وتيره
من احتراخيص السلاح للمستوطنين
الاسرائيليين ونحن بان همم الكثير من
الفلسطينيين يقتلون في الشوارع
بسلاح المستوطنين
يعني الجديد والخطير في القرارات التي
اتخذت امس وبالمناسبه جزء من هذه القرارات
لم تعلن لم يتم نشرها انه هذه القرارات
اليوم اخذت البعدين البعد الحكومي انه جزء
من هذه الاجراءات والعقوبات والسياسات
الجديده
ستنفذها الحكومه واجهزها الشرطيه والامنيه
والعسكريه والجزء الاخر الغير معلن هم
العصابات المستوطنين يعني لم يتحدث
الاعلامي العبري كثيرا عن عشرات المركبات
والمنازل
وهمم الحقول الزراعيه التي تم احراقها منذ
نهايه عطله السبت بالامس مساء الامس قبل
24 ساعه يعني بالاربعه 24 ساعه الماضيه
شهدت كل مفترقات ومدن الضفه عشرات الهجمات
المستوطنين
للنواه صلب
لجماعهوزو بين كبير هؤلاء
لهم ان يخرجوا من بيوتهم وان يعتدوا على
ممتلكات وان يحرقوا المنازل وان يحرقوا
السيارات والمركبات وان يصيبوا الكثير من
الفلسطينيين بدون الدعم والحمايه الامني
من الجيش والشباك والشرطه وبالغطاء
السياسي من قبل الحكومه اللي باعت بين
كبير
وبالمناسبهرش هو احد مؤسسين ما يسمى عصابه
التلال وشبيبه التلال وجماعات تدفيع الثمن
فبالتالي انه انه اعطاء ادوار انه اليوم
الحكومه الاسرائيليه باتجاه ما ينسجن مع
سياساته وليست معنيه بلدان مع الامريكان
تحديدا وقبيل همم زياره وزير الخارجيه
بساعات ثم الجانب الخطير في القارات التي
اتخذت وهي تستهدف ليس فقط الفدائيين
المنافدين العمليات وعائلاتهم همم من
الدرج الاولى تستهدف البيئه الشعبيه
الحاضنه للع اليات اليوم في كان هدم
لمجزره ل 14 منزل بمدينه القدس المحتله
اليوم الدوريات الاداره المدنيه التي
اصبحت مسؤوليه سنيترج وزير المسؤول عن
الاداره المدنيه باتت تراقب كل مليمتر
بالضفه الغربيه وتمنع حتى المزارعين من
الدخول الى اراضيهم في منطقه جيم بمعنى
انه اليوم اسرائيل ادركت اخيرا ان
العمليات الفرديه الحاليه يعني تاج بيئه
فلسطينيه
همم هل يمكن القول بان نتنياهو يستفيد من
التصعيد مع مع الفلسطينيين ارضاءا للجناح
اليمين او الاكثر التطرفا في حكومه تصعيدا
وتهدئه همم مع الجانب الامريكي او تلبيه
لدعوات من الجانب الامريكي لمساعدته في
الملفات الاقليميه لاسيه امام بتاعه ايران
في المنطقه
حول ان هذه نحل ان اعمال العنف
ستحل وما تعنيه هذه الاعمال للحكومه حكومه
الائتلاف سياسيه كما ذكر ضيفكم هنالك ربما
بعض النقاشات حول كيفيه
التعامل
الاسرائيليين مع الفلسطينيين واا اشراكهم
بالتاكيد ان هذا ليس هو التحالف الحاكم
الذي تم جمعه من اجله ايجاد حلولنا
للعلاقه بين الاسرائيلين وفلسطين على
العكس تماما ان نتنياهو والذي يريد ان
يتعامل مع هذه العناصر ولدينا بعض
الشخصيات في حكومته ترغب بعمليات وتصعيدي
التوتر في الاراضي في الاراضي المحتله انا
اعتقد ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه ست- تمتلك
ولمانيه للتعامل مع اكثر من قضيه اكيد
ايران ستكون نقطه مهمه للنقاش وهذه نقطه
ربما من جهه سيكون هنالك مصالح مشتركه ومن
جهه اخرى لدينا وضع في الماضي حيث ان
الاداره الديمقراطيه ورئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو اختلفوا بشكل كبير حول
الاستراتيجيه الخاصه بايران وايضا
بالاضافه الى ذلك لدينا جهود اضافيه في
المنطقه من اجل تطبيع العلاقات بين
اسرائيل بين جيرانها بالتالي سيكون هنالك
الكثير من المواضيع للنقاش لكن بالنسبه
للولاده المتحده سيكون الامر بشكل اساسي
تنجربه
بالاستماع بشكل كبير اكبر من الحديد
كيف يمكن ان تتفاعل حكومه نتنياهو بجناحها
اليمين المتطرف مع اجنده زياره انترنت الى
الى المنطقه وفي مقدمتها كما اسلفنا هو
التهدئه في فلسطين خدمه للملفات الخارجيه
لا سيما همم يعني همم دائره اتفاق ابرامز
او التطبيع مع الدول العربيه
الحكومه الحاليه في اسرائيل ليست هي
الحكومه التي كانت الاداره الامريكيه
تتمنى او تفضل ان تكون بما فيها يعني همم
لا يعقل ان تستوعب الاداره الامريكيه عن
تتشارك مع همم بين كثير ومترج وهمم الذين
قدمت ضدهم عشرات لوائح الاتهام بالمحاكم
الاسرائيليه لوحدها ولكن بالنهايه هذا
صندوق الانتخابات والاداره الامريكيه ستجد
نفسها امام واقع ووجدت نفس امام مواقع
انها مضطره للتعامل بين كبير وما اسمهم
اعضاء بالمجلس الامني
الوزاري المصغر واعضاء بالكابينات ال- ال-
الامني السياسي بمعنى انه اطقم الامريكيه
الاطقم الامنيه والاستخباراتيه والعسكريه
والسياسيه الموجوده في اسرائيل الان تلتقي
وتجتمع مع بني كبير ولكن السياسه
الامريكيه لا يمكن ان تلتقي مع ترجمه
مشروع بين كبير ومترج لذلك الزيارات
الامريكيه للمنطقه تحاول ضبط الامور
والحفاظ على مجموعه من المسائل المرتبطه
بالخطوط الحمر اتجاه السياسي الامريكيه
منها عدم الذهاب كثيرا بترجمه مشروع بنك
فيروس الذي سيؤدي بالنهايه الى سقوط
السلطه
وانتهاء مرحله السلطه والانتقال الى مرحله
ما بعد السلطه الفلسطينيه وبقائها اعتقد
انه حاجه امريكيه ومصلحه امريكيه
والامريكان يعون ذلك ويضغطون بالاجابه
رائعه مساله ثانيه
اتجاه المسجد الاقصى الامريكان من انه
احداث تغيير جوهري بالوضع القائم من
المسجد الاقصى من الممكن
العلاقه الاسرائيليه الاردنيه في هذا
السياق
هذا السيد عادل انتهى الوقت تماما همم
اطراف فلسطينيه تقول بانه لا يكفي من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تتحفظ على
سموتش وبنكفير طالما لا تتخذ الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اجراءات
وربما قرارات صارمه تجاه حكومه نتنياهو
فان لا زياره اا بلانكن ولا غيره من همم
القاده الامريكيين ستنفع في تغيير نهج
حكومه نتنياهو عدد البعض منها السيد عادل
قبل قليل ما رايك سيد الاخير
بشكل
الاسرائيلي في الخليل شكرا لكما الى هنا
تنتهي الحلقه من برنامج
الى اللقاء بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]